[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week like we said this week has been
bone-headed as [ __ ] it's been a great
week though yeah no tons of very
revealing
right great news for democracy we had
the kansas uh turned down uh the the
amendment to
take away the rights
of women and liberty and bodily autonomy
from women in kansas they said [ __ ] no
not just no but [ __ ] no yep to that
amendment which is great um there were
some great uh outcomes for some of these
primaries i believe uh going forward
this proves that there are people still
out there that are confident in our
democracy they want to participate and
engage in our democracy and i think
that's important but also we had some
side drama
side drama
of like the pact act john stewart um
in the last week and into this week
passing the helping getting that across
the finish line we have a couple of
those senators on the bonehead list for
that and then we have some drama down in
florida but also this alex jones trial
holy [ __ ] gabe what do you think about
this stuff it is look you know we talked
about it yesterday on the show like you
know how like the ability to hear you
know in the courtroom and stuff and we
were comparing it to the amber uh heard
johnny depp trial like you know the the
quality of the production there is right
there they knew what was happening they
had two celebrities that were going
head-to-head that were saying you know
he said this and she said that and
everyone was interested when it came
time to this alex jones trial nobody
could have anticipated the [ __ ] that was
going to happen little fingers here you
had you know almost fights there you had
revealing text messages over here like
yeah even even even seditious sexting
between roger stone
and
alex jones kind of reveal we haven't
seen it yet we haven't seen and i don't
know if we do we want to see the
intimate goals well i don't know you
know
depending on who you are yeah we'll
definitely we'll definitely jump into
that because alex jones is another
person that was on bonehead of the week
but yeah that was a whole that whole
court case i don't think anyone expected
anything to come of that outside of like
we're gonna decide what the amount is
for this that what had already been
decided as like he was guilty of
defamation and now what is the actual
financial amount that will be awarded
right and we have some news we have some
news on that too but let's go to the
boneheads here we have senator rand paul
he's been on our list a lot
as well as senator ted cruz i mean again
we say this all the time like i feel
like every week we get here we're like
ah these [ __ ] could be here every
single week oh yeah these guys these
guys set up camp and they're like
they're like on the bench ready to go
and they're like put me in coach put me
in i'm ready do you think do you think
they're in like
the senate gym and they're like how do
we get on bone into the week yeah yeah
well i mean
ted cruz is you know he's like trying to
dribble a basketball he's like how do i
get on bonehead of the week how do i get
on bonehead of the week you know but
really these two senators are on the
bone of the week because of the pact act
right like in the response to it their
own individual responses to what
happened they've got them on this list
this week right and one really the the
senator rand paul it was more about his
response on the floor
um tell the folks about that as i find
the clip here of rand paul on the floor
right so rand paul tried to have the
paul amendment added to the pact act
which got overwhelmingly
down voted it was 70 to 90 or 7 to 90 is
what the end result so 90 saying they
don't want this amendment in there which
would basically uh change the amount of
funds that were given to uh to help
um fund the pact act and it was to lower
uh foreign aid to different countries um
so that they could help pay off the pact
act
and uh it was it had marsha blackburn
mike lee ron johnson like all of the
people who have either you know they
have no purpose they they serve no
purpose in the senate they've attempted
to
you know how about you define what a
woman is hey we should try to get uh
mike pence these fake electors like all
of these people are terrible bone-headed
human beings so it i'm not surprised at
all that these were the seven people
that voted for this dumb asses uh
amendment that thankfully got voted down
right well you know every time rand paul
speaks whether it's on the floor on the
record or in a committee or even
when you say on the floor is that
because he's like a mop head well it
could be like you know that that's a
good point but when he speaks i i want
to be his neighbor more and more and
more
i think every day people hear him speak
and they're like really like especially
for something like this like the things
that he says in this moment to be like
i'm right and here is why i'm right
more people are probably like yeah i
wouldn't mind being his neighbor as well
you know
really i really would like to be this
guy's neighbor like every day be his
neighbor let's listen to rand paul here
try to tell us now that the cdc is right
and asthma that veterans has is just
asthma it's no big deal gabe care of our
veterans and keep our country strong
this bill puts our economy though at
risk by creating presumptions of service
connection for the most common
availments this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
again again he's acting like he's acting
he's acting like he's doing the gas
price the gas price thing like oh this
is going to affect the economy gets like
who gives a [ __ ] right people are dying
because of their service to our country
well he's also i mean like he's like i'm
you know he's he's attempting to make
that whole i'm a doctor argument and
it's like no you [ __ ] dumbass you're
not uh and if anyone i would say we
don't have time to dig into this show
but if anyone's interested just google
rand paul
is he an actual doctor and the things
you will read and find out are not
surprising but also
here's what i'll tell you is um
go to twitter and copy or do some
screenshots of
googling is rand paul an actual doctor
that'd be fantastic
tag us in them that would be great let's
listen
for example this legislation creates a
presumption of service connection for
vietnam veterans for hypertension
but according to the cdc fifty percent
of men and forty four percent of women
in the united states have hypertension
you know you could do a what was that
with almost every single clip of these
[ __ ] boneheads because he's like the
cdc according to the cdc like what what
was that like really honestly now you're
going to believe the cdc right that's
the thing that you believe them
everything else all the million people
that was killed there in the pandemic
mask vaccines [ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that nonsense you're like well maybe the
monkey pox this like cases of polio
we've seen come up now like everything
the cdc says about all these other
diseases and all these health uh issues
he goes yeah [ __ ] it everything
he's like hypertension and asthma
those are the ones we should listen to
them about
everything he says it makes me want to
be more and more neighborly
to rand
i kind of now have this visual of rand
paul as
the like evil mr rogers and he's like
will you be my neighbor and it was like
[ __ ] yeah i'll be your neighbor like
dark rogers kind of yeah like a dark
like a dark rogers you know and you know
he sits down and he's like will you be
my neighbor and everyone
all the kids are like yeah okay right
you goddamn right we would let's finish
this bone end more than 60 percent of
people over the age of 60 have
hypertension
in total the cdc estimates that 106
estimates that 116 million americans
have hypertension
the legislation also creates a
presumption of service connection for
global war on terror veterans for asthma
the cdc estimates that one in 12 people
have asthma which is approximately 25
million americans do you think when he
went to his staffer and he was like hey
can you go give me some cdc numbers on
this this and this they're like what was
that
yeah they're like why and he was well
i'm trying to make a point a point about
what well i need to prove how asthma
is a way in which i can make this whole
like pack act not really go for the it's
like the i'm sure like the intern of the
aide was like
why why would you do that also it's like
the same argument because he's trying to
be like oh 25 million people like are
you either are you trying to argue that
that's a lot of people or a little
amount of people and then it goes the
same argument that people made during
covid which is like well only like one
percent of people are they are like
affected this way and it's like yeah but
one percent of a population that is
nearly 350 million people that's a lot
of people when you're talking about like
the debts right
so whenever you or you know whatever the
percentage the low percentage that they
would claim it's like even one person
dying from this thing is bad right why
are we accepting any greater number than
one
that's [ __ ] crazy well here's here's
the mop head again now this has to do
with the finland uh sweden
membership which he voted for yeah in
the long run the only one he had no what
i mean what he had to give us two cents
what do you say well yeah well let's
listen my reservation merely reasserts
his reservation nearly that's it okay
i'm done i don't i don't even need it i
don't even need any more of this clip i
don't need anymore what is it all of
these republicans lauren bobert and all
these other people are like oh we're
gonna let finland and sweden into nato
why would we do that you know that makes
no sense you know but after a while
these people that were you know have
typically historically been neutral you
know they're like we don't want involved
they're like okay
we're gonna now be involved because the
world is [ __ ] up but we need to
actually take a stance and republicans
are like no
whoa whoa whoa
what will you want to be you want to
like pro democracy what are you ready oh
what are you doing dude no so yeah well
again he's
putting some sort of amendment on the
floor that's not going to get accepted
this is all and he voted for it in the
first place this is all to get on fox
news
he does this [ __ ] all the time what josh
hawley voted against the bill the only
one to vote against it so he could get
on tucker carlson's show like literally
that's the reason i even said this on
settering john's podcast i said look the
reason why josh hawley voted against
this thing isn't because he you know
this thing that thing this it literally
he was like well if i don't know him i'm
the only one vote no putin's little
puppet putin's little you know fellatio
will let me on his show on white
privilege tonight with tucker carlson
he'll bring me on and i'll get to talk
about putin how great putin is because
tucker loves putin and that's why he
voted against it it's all for the fox
news clips it's all you know the other
thing that makes me think of is when
they're done as soon as they're done
with the vote there are cameras always
ready in like the rotunda area right
right right on that floor and they're
all waiting to be like all right can we
get you in for an interview so-and-so is
live right now and wants to ask you
about the vote
but the acoustics and the echo you can
hear it during the interview it is very
like very powerful the way that the
audio from your your your talking will
carry throughout the rest of the
the uh outside of the chambers in the
rotunda area
and i always think like walking through
if i were to ever walk through when one
of those interviews are happening like
one
saying [ __ ] back
to echo and overtake their interview but
two like people walking by and having to
listen to the dumb
stupid [ __ ] that these people say just
to get on fox news he's like oh i voted
against them entering nato because it's
like that's you that's it why would you
even why why why why are you trying to
be
it's just it's a pain in the ass to
listen to but i can only imagine what
it's like for people who are actually
inside of me like i just wanted to have
like two moments to think to myself
without hearing rand paul or josh hawley
[ __ ] blabber on about why they voted
against this thing that they should have
voted for right well it makes you again
want to be very neighborly with these
[ __ ] and uh speaking of
[ __ ] we have ted cruz there
could be like a gazillion reasons just
this week why ted cruz is on here but i
have a clip here i guess this was uh
from today or yesterday where they were
having an oversight
committee meeting
for fbi oversight with
fbi director ray
and ted cruz i guess gets out his
[ __ ] boot i've not seen this i
haven't watched this he gets
watch this
violent extremist militia well i will
self-report right now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them
what the [ __ ]
so here you go again here you go at the
political theater to get on fox news
this [ __ ] takes he didn't take
his boot off he wore a different pair of
shoes in there because he had a [ __ ]
boot ready to go
these boots are made for walking and
do you know what the gonzales battle
flag is
no go ahead it does it's the dumb ass
well it's not dumb ass and it's dumb ass
in the response or in the aspect of of
of ted cruz that come and take it that's
what that battle flag says
so that's what he's trying to push he's
like every day i wear these boots and on
the back it's the gonzalez battle flag
and on the gonzalez battle flag it says
come and take it which is the same [ __ ]
that he says on his mask whenever they
talk about [ __ ] guns whatever it
might be ted cruz is always saying come
and take it you want my gun come and
take it you want this liberty come and
take it you want these rights come and
take it and then he'll be like oh
actually uh yes go and take those rights
away from women and anyone who has a
marginalized community that's what ted
cruz says right they do he believes yeah
[ __ ]
ted cruz is like threatening the
government he says come and take this
thing from me and then him as the
government says aha yes i will come and
take those things from you right right
like that's the hypocrisy of this party
and that is the hypocrisy of this
[ __ ] wish.com version of wolverine
well i was gonna play the fist bump but
i think this is as despicable as that is
uh i don't think anyone needs to see the
fist bump again where he i can only
imagine the smell as well if he was
really wearing those clothes and he had
the shoe off oh my god with that whole
time
and sat down i don't know
and let that thing sit there and
marinate so the whole right i think
smell it i think if he's really wearing
those boots he had it on the whole time
up until the point of which he had to
talk or
he took it off as soon as he sat down
he's like well can't get up now because
i got one boot on one bit off
and he's like i'm just waiting for the
point where i can slam that boot down
and say i've got the gonzales battle
flag on my boot
doesn't really make your point any
stronger yeah such an idiot let's watch
let's watch this bonehead do this bone
edit thing one more
time um just because i think it's
[ __ ] stupid and hilarious violent
extremist militia well i will
self-report right now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them
did you see mike lee behind him he's
like he's such a dumb buck yeah look at
mike lee here he's like oh my god did he
practice this mike lee's thinking is in
his mind
how many times had this idiot practiced
this before he got it right oh my god
and michael he's like put your [ __ ]
boot back on you now somebody's like
that's what that smell was i was
wondering what smelled like
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] wrapped in you know
whatever [ __ ]
dead possums ass oh my god it's like you
know it's like an anchorman like it
smells like bigfoot's dick you know that
just that whole that whole line the
whole lines of the jokes of the
throwaway like one-liners from that
moment where he comes out with the
[ __ ]
uh sex panther cologne that's probably
what
ted cruz's boot smells like
and as well as his feet
oh
nasty that's nasty speaking of nasty
is a nasty nasty senator he's a nasty
[ __ ] well let's uh let's go to
another nasty son of a [ __ ] uh governor
ron desantis he's our alpha cuck of the
week alpha cuck why did he get alpha
cuck what happened here with ron
desantis i mean i can only imagine but
what what's the what's the deal with ron
desantis gabe
well uh you know we've got these whole
rights being taken away in florida and
then he decides that it was the
uh it was the county attorney who was it
again i uh yeah i forget the name but
he's he's like a state attorney right
and he's and he's he's uh
suspending the state attorney uh recount
has a video here let's see if um we can
get some
tampa prosecutor right he took his
stance against criminalizing abortion
because this person was like yeah
we're not going to do this thing that
you want to do you [ __ ] fascist
dictator right he's deciding not to
enforce the unconstitutional law that
ron
wants him to women have rights
and they should be able to do what they
want with their own bodies and you
[ __ ] want to be trump 2.0 get your
[ __ ] grubby little hands out of these
women you know right well let's listen
to uh captain fascist here tell us why
he's a whiny little [ __ ]
the constitution of florida has vested
the veto power in the governor
not in individual state attorneys and so
when you flagrantly violate your oath of
office when you make yourself above the
law
you have violated your duty
you have neglected your duty and you are
displaying a lack of competence to be
able to reform those duties and so today
we are suspending
state attorney andrew warren effective
immediately
should now do trump yeah
trump this is one of those ron desantis
is one of those people i mean we saw it
before with the kids with masks on and
he was like don't wear the mask don't do
that don't this political theater
[ __ ]
but you look behind ron desantis right
he tells these people to be there
whether they're pro ron desantis and
fascism or they're like oh the [ __ ]
chief told me how to show up here
but these people behind him in suits and
also in their actual uh law enforcement
you know uniform
are there as like a sign of if you cross
me
as governor
i will [ __ ] you up right and that is not
how we do things in this country you
can't just say what a rule is and then
say if you do anything which again right
you're taking rights away from women so
the fact that this guy is suspended for
trying to
acknowledge that women should have these
rights and they should determine what
they should do with their own body as
opposed to ron desantis saying
if there's an abortion
i'm coming after you
and it's like one it's none of your
[ __ ] business dude why you guys are
also fascinated and obsessed with what
someone else does with their own body
and their own home with their own just
[ __ ]
bubble
freedom
this is the party of freedom it's
ridiculous it's absolutely ridiculous so
ron desantis stands in front of all
these people and he's just a [ __ ]
cuck
right here's what yeah he is a cuck he
he's getting he gets cocked all the time
and the reason why he's gonna get cucked
here is exactly what kansas did to the
referendum to try to take away women's
rights because if you really look at the
makeup of kansas
it feels really similar to the makeup of
the voters in electorate uh like states
like texas
georgia florida who seem really red
but on issues where i don't know someone
takes away an entire group of people's
liberty
right
they they're not so [ __ ] red right
and i believe that in the american
people and in this democracy and that's
why i've been so confident about this as
long as we engage in our democracy
america is going to project this idea
that you can just take away [ __ ]
rights from a group of people like wait
a second what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and rather it's kansas rather it's
the dobbs case where the supreme court
overturns roe v wade or it's [ __ ]
hitler jr down in florida's ron desantis
trying to be a king fascist down there
trying to be like you said trump 2.0
and trying to trying to run rough shot
over liberty freedom rights
and and just plain being unamerican and
unpatriotic and he's the example of what
they want to do with with the united
states government yeah as a fascist
state that's the blueprint we've talked
about it a hundred times before and uh
you know ron desantis he deserves i do i
do want to add one more thing on there
yeah if you've noticed like in
california we've had cases kind of
rising in in terms of monkey pox
illinois has had cases florida has had
cases right uh just uh on thursday uh or
i think it was thursday that uh
that
joe biden was uh he had announced that
there is now a state of emergency around
monkey pox right we are a health
emergency right and they are taking the
appropriate steps because we do not want
a covid lockdown you know 2.0 kind of
situation happen where we've got monkey
pox spreading
between communities and people not doing
anything to make sure that they are
staying away from others uh as well
while they get treatment
now the benefit of having monkey pox
right now is that we do and we we can
treat it with the smallpox vaccine
and so ron desantis is saying no no no
no we're not doing this fear [ __ ] again
let me just make this clear this is not
fear [ __ ] this is just the appropriate
way in terms of how you handle a health
issue right we have the appropriate
steps and protocols we have someone who
is in office as a leader who's not going
to say not my responsibility or it'll
miraculous go away by easter or all you
got to do is shove light up your ass and
inject bleach we don't have someone like
that we have something
is that the monkey box vaccine shove a
light up your eyes i think you know i
don't know if those things really work
for covid but trump might tell you that
that is how you treat monkey pucks it
could be it could be now you know that's
a good point because we went through
this with a pandemic and it always
confused me because ron desantis if you
ask like you know what are you
politically he would say something
stupid like i'm a conservative which
he's not a conservative at all he's a
fascist but here's the thing the
conservative
of conservative person a conservative
leader
or a conservative government would
actually be in favor of things that like
you're talking about they'd be like hey
we need to make sure that this isn't
spreading we need to keep track of it we
need to do what we can do to make sure
people don't get disease because this
thing could kill people it can hurt
people it's a health issue
a liberal type of government be like you
know let's just see what happens yeah
like it is what it is right it is what
it is you can't change it let's just
keep going about it and that's the
confusing part to me that's the
confusing part to me is they
doing this type of dance around this
stuff where again it's not
you know
and i think me me you and david bender
talked about it the other day this isn't
really republican democrat anymore right
we're in we're in an age where these
things don't really mean the things that
they meant 10 15 years ago
and they're trying to use words and come
up with ways to describe
their political stance and the way they
want to govern with words that aren't
the same when it's just pure blooded
fascism that right on desantis wants to
have and that's why
he's the applica because he's wants to
be king fascist down in florida now
we're fascist and and the last thing too
is a fascist will also make sure
to scrub out anyone else's voice
so when you have an audit that it was
like a few weeks ago or a month ago or
so you know uh was also covered when i
did the interview with dr eric feiglding
one of the things was the fact that
there was an audit in florida and they
did find out that you know
um
the there was manipulation with the data
that was coming out of florida to say
how many cases and debts there were
and that the whistleblower who was
actually running against matt gates and
his district this year
came forward and ron desantis was the
person who's like no no we're going to
arrest you you shouldn't have done that
you shouldn't have talked about this and
that is exactly what a dictator and a
fascist will try to do is they will
silence any voice that does not in
agreement with theirs if you don't
follow the cult if you don't follow our
regime and our voice on what we say then
we cast you out and we silence you
as a as a traitor
and that is not democracy
that is that is the opposite of
democracy
so um
if we can move to the dishonorable
mention because we we did alphacut here
right yeah yeah but the dishonorable
mention it kind of
i don't know it bleeds in with the
winner here oh yeah yeah they kind of a
chair right it's kind of a shared story
almost
so who is this dishonorable mention
because i i've never heard this name
before you know
he's not a name that you would probably
hear he is known
as a lawyer so for anyone watching right
now and listening this is uh andino
reynold he is the lawyer for alex jones
in this defamation trial that was
happening in texas so what is the f
standboard have we figured that out this
standpoint
does it stand for [ __ ] fernando what
what's the what's the uh well i tried to
find what the f stood for and i cannot
find it couldn't find it i did i did
find i did find a video though here
um
and it might be
someone may
may have made a joke of this i couldn't
imagine who but this is
so i think you put him as a dm and the
reason why is because he kind of [ __ ]
up in the trial right well not in the
trial so much as in the evidence
and not really
you know staying on top of things right
and it created this moment in the alex
jones trial where alex jones is kind of
you know slapped in the face with
reality
it was a beautiful moment oh it is a
beautiful moment it's beautiful so let's
watch and this goes to tell you or this
goes to show you earlier when we were
talking about how you know amber hurt
and johnny depp they had prepared for
this type of
drama right this trial was like oh yeah
we'll give you a you know a feed and you
can watch into it but nobody anticipated
the type of [ __ ] show
that was going to come out of this thing
right well even law and crime here on
their youtube channel because they had
one camera in the room right and it
appeared there was another camera room
we've tried to determine who that camera
is and then there's the zoom camera
which is like the the courtroom record
camera right that they're broadcasting
on the courtroom's youtube channel who
knows maybe somebody's doing a
documentary about alex it could be it
could be that's what they're setting up
over there that it's that and it could
be alex jones trying to capitalize on
this where he has a camera in the room
for a documentary who knows um but here
is the law and crime but someone may
have someone may have been in put some
credits on the in this let's watch mr
jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy
of your entire cell phone with every
text message you've sent for the past
two years and when informed
did not take any steps to identify it as
privileged or protected in any way
and as of two days ago it felt free and
clear into my position and that is how i
know you lied to me
[Music]
oh my god i can't it was it had to be
done i had to make it
i don't i don't know if this lawyer like
the the sandy hook lawyer if he
practiced that or what but i mean it was
just like
it was so perfect because look at the
this is the look on alex jones's face
but not only but
also the angle they were on him and
they're like all right quick we want to
pan over
jones right like get the reaction the
law and crime whoever's running that
camera they did a perfect job perfect
job amazing
even with the limited amount of
production that you had in the room you
did a fantastic job whoever's running
the camera wrong crime it was unexpected
delight
oh my god because
you know of course
that wasn't the end of this drama but
this but this attorney you saw him
sitting there yeah right
he was like oh just like finger in the
mouth tapping his lip he's like
right here's here's the uh here's here
he is um
now i wonder
what do you think gabe because there's a
lot of theories out there right and i
know we've talked about a few of them
in private and even on the show there's
a few theories that say that maybe this
guy maybe this guy did this on purpose
but there could be a lot of different
reasons why he did it on purpose right i
i want to believe that there's not this
coin you know right well you would i
mean the thing so what happened was you
know there said oh we want all of the
text messages that have to that mention
sandy hook we want to see what he was
saying
during this time about i mean you mean
the sandy took hook attorneys were
working right he was like i want to see
the text message i want to see the
communications that were all mentioning
sandy hook to to to show
that there was intent like you knew this
was a lie
and you continued to push it right
and you did it to millions of people and
these these victims these families had
to deal with even more stress and trauma
now
they asked for that and what ended up
happening was three years not even two
years three years of text messages and
communication had been sent over to the
plaintiff which was the attorney for the
sandy hook parents and he
gets this [ __ ] and he's like oh my god
this is a [ __ ] gold mine right which
by the way i'm sure he's already gone
through and searched for a bucket roger
stone and stuart rhodes and like trump
like all these things well so i was i
was on staring john's show with kelly
jones oh alex jones's ex-wife right
and
you know we were kind of talking about
this and she actually said that that she
didn't know if
if alex
actually text a lot she thought it would
probably be dictation text
so she thought that it's going to be
like alex but can you imagine
can you imagine
alex jones
like dictating his text like he does his
show and the demons
and the democrats the demons the cabal
the blood sucking the ball comfy i mean
he's just sitting there dictating this
into the phone so
roger stone right come on
you know i don't know what that's come
over dinner come come [ __ ]
shot on my balls like there's something
it's he's got his dad he's got intimate
messages so that's that's the next uh
thing that i i want to show here in this
whole drama of
these text messages
is the fact that
because well we were on the show when
when that moment happened we were on the
show and we kind of pulled it up yeah
yeah and and i was like hey you know
that like at the time i was like two
years like 2022
2020
2021 jan 6 is right in the middle there
like
is there any possibility that this guy
said something alex jones mentioned in
preparation
and uh during the day and after the day
with certain people that are of interest
to the january 6 committee i wouldn't be
surprised if they came for that and then
after the show had ended i think within
an hour so rolling stone had an article
that was saying uh the the jan six
committee was subpoenaing what was ma
was requesting a subpoena of those
of those text messages from the sandy
hook lawyer but it enters in it enters
in a new chara well not a new character
but a new character to this trial right
but one we're familiar with in the jan
six saga
with the oath keepers and the proud boys
which is roger stone and i'm trying to
find the clip of the moment
when
when the sandy hook lawyers describe
here it is here it is describe the the
uh messages
from alex jones to roger stone let's
listen
and things like like mr jones and his
intimate messages with roger stone are
not confidential they're not traits
none of them so he says his intimate his
intimate conversations yeah it's re you
know i i would
think that private like you yeah yeah
you would you uh well i don't know maybe
he said private he was good to say
private or he was thinking privates you
know those are i don't know i don't know
it seems like this attorney
chose that word engine very simple i
mean look he's got a piece of paper in
front of he's got his whole like this is
why he's you know probably in
preparation knowing
that they're like oh [ __ ] everyone is
putting alex jones on blast and mocking
him on all of these different channels
and and news stations because of that
we've had your text for 12 days now
and uh
nobody said that it was protected and
then alexander's like
oh [ __ ] right and he's like oh well
there's your perry mason but we like
tried to recover from it yeah and he
couldn't such a [ __ ] because the damage
was already done right so of course it
was
the the plaintiff the the uh
uh the the sandy hook lawyer came in
prepared he had the whole thing he's
like this is why
we will not allow these text messages to
be removed or struck and or struck from
the record
because and then he wrote down intimate
messages
with roger stone right he went through
he made sure to go through those things
because he's seen he's he's seen this
well he's either seen him or heard him
whatever he's messing are solemn saw the
pictures
pictures that were sent back and forth
that they were sharing i don't know what
they were doing but yeah but but again
like we said on the show um before
he knew what he was doing
and he intentionally whether he took a
cue like a page out of the jan six book
but he knew exactly what
what type of language would get the
clicks and would get people to follow up
and write stories about it right the
intimate word was important well and i
also think that actually invoking roger
stone's name is important because i
think what he's doing here
is he's he's calling
very specifically that hey
there might be some things the select
committee wants to hear and wants to
listen to and see here um it's and the
roger stone stuff is juicy
it's juicy and which leads me to
uh on our bonehead of the week
contestants the winner of the bone end
of the week
of course mr alex jones how could he not
be where he was like it wouldn't even
erase
right out of the gate man he was like
well it's in and it's mainly because of
these text messages yeah um obviously
now we know we know in the trial we have
the first verdict here now the 4.1
million on the actual damages that is
going to be awarded to the sandy hook
family in this case um it look they're
going to
be convening for the
punitive damages which
obviously this is uh and it seems to be
in favor of alex jones but like we've
discussed on the minus touch network we
did a little uh news clip for them where
we
we talked about that breaking news of
that verdict where
the the punitive damages only appears
that it can be twice as much in this
case as the actual damages which was
awarded the 4.1 so it seems like the
most that's going to come out of this is
possibly 12.3 million something like
that right all right plus i think
there's attorney fees that he has to pay
or something and then there's also the
fines that right that's right
because he's this isn't the beginning of
it this is just that he's already guilty
right this is them deciding just the
amount right it's whatever million and a
half or so and finds that he's owed to
those families already because right
that he's been trying to pull right so
so in in summation the 4.1
plus now the jury may come back with
punitive and they may come up with some
kind of pie in the sky number like 100
or 150 or 200 whatever that case is and
then
possibly
um
it could be the just double the amount
but the only amount no matter what they
come back with the maximum is double of
the 4.1 but also there's cases in
connecticut there's another cases in
texas so alex jones the bone end of the
week is not out of the woods here but i
want to play you i found this i think
ronya ron posted here
this is hilarious this is actually alex
jones with his attorney in his studio
trying to explain the text messages
and you can tell why alex jones is
terrified that these text messages are
out in the open it has nothing to do
with these sandy hook cases not a
goddamn thing and i actually i end a
conversation with kelly jones his
ex-wife that she's gonna try to get
these text messages too because she
still has ongoing lawsuits with him and
he's not he's not scared of that alex
jones projects exactly what he's scared
of exactly where the evidence is because
he has his attorney on his show to tell
his audience don't believe the stuff
that they're going to say because it's
the truth don't believe it don't believe
the thing that they're just repeating
verbatim of what i sent write my text
right watch this
watch this um weird piece of footage
every major platform is alex jones's
phone has fallen in
to the january 6 committee's hands
here's my lawyer or counselor or advisor
robert barnes give me a stick here's my
i don't know what this guy here's this
dude i got off the street and i sent it
to my lawyer right this guy was one of
the bench outside he's like here's one
of the guys that [ __ ] up and gave all
of the text messages to the other side
he's going to explain
what he why why he [ __ ] up yeah this
is so this is so dumb number one
he's lying here
where he's trying to tell his audience
that the january 6 committee already has
these which that's not the case yeah my
belief is here and we need to track this
down of exactly the timeline but i would
bet
that there were attorneys
from the january 6 select committee that
as soon as that moment happened someone
ran in a room like holy [ __ ] did you
just see what happened in austin texas
yeah like nope they pulled up the video
and immediately they they started on the
subpoena for those records now because
we do know we do know that the select
committee has subpoenaed those records
we do not know if the doj has done it
yet we don't know that but here's the
thing doj is gonna get those records
from the from the select committee at
some point because they have come to an
agreement on trading information they
just the timing
is a little lagged there but let's watch
how this attorney explains
to alex jones's audience how this is
this is all cents don't believe the
thing that anyone but alex tells you
absolutely i've been doing
constitutional law for a long time and
while i am not a representative of
infowars i am a representative that
cares about the constitution and in that
capacity the fourth the fifth and the
sixth amendment to the united states
constitution prohibit somebody from
illicitly obtaining your attorney-client
privilege protected information so here
we go so here we go here we go so this
this thing here where he's like he's
trying to explain amendments to alex
jones's audience because you know they
can't they can't make it past the first
or second amendment right right right
they know that they know the fifth one
now i mean like right oh hey eric trump
is that at 500 times yeah
over 100 times
right
they know that fifth one really good but
they skipped they skipped three four and
they
figured out five now they're the six so
he's trying to explain to their audience
what amendments are and which which
numbers mean which thing let's listen
this goes all the way back to andy
griffith shows in the 1960s this is how
universally understood this precept and
principle is so what the january 6
committee is doing why did why did he
say the andy griffith show what the [ __ ]
is i don't know
he's like i don't know i don't know did
they did they do like a big survey to
see like they're like other shows alex
jones
his demographic is watching nick at
night and they're watching the andy
griffith show
and they're like yep people will get
this reference people well here's the
thing probably because the people who
are buying those herbal supplements are
an older demographic and they're
probably the ones who are watching that
show probably well and that's what
they're like you got to give in you got
to give it a time a time period
reference because i know the exact one
i'm going to use andy griffith show
all right okay oh my god which i'm i'm
not dog in the andy griffith show i love
andy griffith yeah i love it it's a very
odd reference to me right and you know
what's funny about the andy griffith
show it's a bunch of [ __ ] liberals in
the real small rural town in america
which is kind of funny i don't know i'm
just saying let's listen to robert
barnes constitutional lawyer who is
standing outside info wars headquarters
is violating the fourth amendment right
against unreasonable searches the fifth
amendment right to due process of law
and the sixth amendment right to council
by seizing and stealing attorney-client
privileged communications that cannot
constitutionally belong to them it is an
outrage that should concern every
american because in this case like so
many other cases alex jones is everybody
and everybody is alex jones uh no
they're not no no they're not no
a big [ __ ] you to robert barnes do not
nope don't do that don't do that let's
let's just make something clear nobody
stole these text messages nobody
illegally obtained these text messages
what what happened was that alex jones
attorney the person who may made the dm
this week the dishonorable mention and
dino rainal willingly gave those things
because they were requested
and right do he didn't give just the
sandy hook references of text messages
he gave everything for three years and
then when he note when when the when the
sandy hook lawyer even said hey you send
us all these text messages they didn't
say [ __ ] they didn't
they filed the actual paper that said
hey you you sent me everything this is
not this is more than what i wanted and
then once he went to that 12-day period
which is the rule in the court if
there's no response to that then there's
no big deal and really um alex jones
tried to uh get the judge to give a
mistrial this is like the 18 000 time
right right to try to do a mister off
but they were trying to use this
argument that it was illegally and it
was certain
yeah the lawyers came forward and was
like hey you know we want to say that
this was privileged information and the
other lawyer from the sandy hook side
was like no no no no you guys have
properly done this in the past so you
know what you're doing you have been
notified and you promptly said oh you
know what this should be removed and
then and in those cases where it was
privileged they gave those messages back
and deleted their copy
so nobody nobody other than the lawyer
for alex jones and alex jones
had those copies of that information
that had been deemed between uh
privilege between client and attorney
right
and now it's another moment where
they're trying to do that and the judge
was like okay first off this is like
your 17th time trying to ask for a
mistrial i'm not going to seal this
information and hide it from people you
guys had time to respond and you didn't
and you have done so in the past so you
know how this works i'm not going to
give you guys a mulligan you guys [ __ ]
up
that's on you here's the clip let's
watch it
what's interesting to me is this is not
the first time
that materials like this have been
inadvertently produced in this case as
you may remember from prior hearings mr
barnes inadvertently produced materials
now in that case some of that
information ended up coming out they
ended up letting you keep some of it
when we ended up talking about it but
there were german community economic
excuse me attorney-client communications
in there which you don't know about
which i do which they did follow 193.3
and they did identify those slides page
numbers said here is the privilege and
when that happened i promptly returned
them and destroyed all my copies
mr reynold is right now
using a fig leaf of this motion to say i
violent to put a fig over his own
malpractice over his own absolute breach
of his duties to his own client and he's
attempting to put that on me
and doing it in front of a televised
that's what he's trying to do
so there it is where he's making his
claim that not [ __ ] that is not
what happened i don't think so you're
not gonna get away with that which is
which is uh it seems to be a reoccurring
thing with this alex jones shout out
because i do want to say i believe the
reason why some of this is happening to
alex jones number one because he has a
big [ __ ] mouth and he won't show you
yeah he won't shut his [ __ ] mouth and
that's and and kelly jones's wife said
that when when we were talking to her
yesterday and she was saying look this
is just narcissism he can't control
himself there's nothing he can do and
she's like i actually to some degree
feel sorry for alex because people think
that this is all put on she said some
degree this is probably a mental illness
like when this judge treats him like
he's six years old
she's like and people are kind of making
fun of it and stuff because it's kind of
funny when she talks down to him but
she's like i actually think the judge
and even i believe and know that alex
he has this mental illness that he's not
capable of knowing this stuff like he's
very capable of knowing some of this
stuff because of his narcissism his ego
and i think that go and it and it
projects on to the attorneys and they're
just like we're going to win this like
you've already lost you've already lost
what are you talking about now i do i do
want to say
that um alex jones is the bonehead of
the week but this decision for the 4.1
million dollars a lot of people are
going to knock it a lot of people are
going to be upset because they don't
feel like this is enough money um but
this this is this is what we see with
justice this is how this civil trial is
playing out and there's gonna be more
civil trials
and i bet gamer i bet they're gonna mic
and camera those other civil trials way
[ __ ] better than way better they're
going to be like all right we need mics
here in the corner here in the car right
below like we need likes everywhere
you'll be you'll be walking it'll be a
land like a like a landmine field of of
just mics that's right right now the the
most interesting part about
when you watch the set or not the
sentencing but the but the actual um the
damage is verdict right right the
verdict of what alex jones is gonna have
to pay the family
the thing that struck me the most and it
kind of pissed me off is he wasn't in
the room and i think it probably pissed
those families off too so i don't know
if those punitive damages if you'll he
doesn't have to be in
in the he doesn't have to be in the
courtroom either for the punitive
damages decision right which is just
it's just more it just shows you that
that they don't give a [ __ ] they're such
[ __ ] boxes
and and they think they're above the law
they're cowards right right that's right
they're scared they will not they will
not face like the only time that he was
in there and had to face the parents
were when the parents were on the
witness stand and he had to look at them
and when they were saying
directly to him you knew what you were
doing was wrong you knew this was wrong
and he just shakes his head and it's it
is the exact behavior of a child who's
like no i didn't do it despite the fact
that there are video records of him on a
show blasting
these families and these victims
and then and in court on the stand
lying to the judge and the rest of the
jurors to be like no i never said that i
didn't do that when he was doing those
things just that past week
he's such a piece of [ __ ] such a piece
of [ __ ] and such a coward for not being
able to show up to see the damages that
he would have to pay so that those
families
could watch as he was given the verdict
of his damages but let's give him his
verdict here from the vote that you guys
gave him for bone end of the week let's
give him his due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
alex jones you are a [ __ ] bonehead
you our audience
has decided you are the bonehead of the
[ __ ] week yeah you are the bone end
of the week and i'm sure here's the
thing i'm sure he will come back up on
bonehead of the week for these other
following
the follow-up trials which he has
another one in texas he has one in
connecticut
like he is not done here no we have
already established he owes well he is
in the millions
of of fines and charges against him more
to come and i hope they [ __ ] take him
for all he's worth just every year this
[ __ ] every last single vile
penny that he's made [ __ ] him
and i appreciate you guys uh doing bone
end of the week every single week voting
go to twitter where you can vote
at tony michael's pod you can also vote
here on youtube so don't forget to
subscribe while you're here if you
haven't subscribed already so you can
vote every single week for bone end of
the week where you decide
you vote we break it down on friday
yep every single friday in the second
hour where we broadcast every single day
gabe monday through friday monday
through friday
on saturday what do we do on saturday we
have a recap the best of boom go
download the recap and then on sunday
what happens uh oh for the people who
missed the friday show of bone out of
the week we got a recap again
boom so go download every single episode
seven days a week on apple spotify
google
get it there
and
thank you for joining us for this
episode of bonehead of the week stick
around we have some announcements right
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]